phare de bel air
en dépit de la dangerosité des côtes
seuls deux phares sont construits sur le
littoral rythme nié celui de sainte
suzanne en 1846 et quarante ans plus
tard celui de la pointe des galets
aujourd'hui disparu le relevé des fonds
marins réalisé dans les années 1840 met
en évidence deux rochers à fleur d'eau
face à la pointe de bel air pour
prévenir le danger menaçant les bateaux
on décide d'y installer un phare une
tour de 20 mètres de haut le surplombe
de style toscan elle rappelle les
colonnes néoclassique du muséum
d'histoire naturelle de saint denis
l'escalier en bois a été entièrement
refait en métal au début des années 2000
73 marches conduisent jusqu'au système
d'éclairage une lentille de fresnel dont
le feu est visible 18 milles nautiques
soit plus de 30 km
entretenu pendant plus de cent quarante
ans par un gardien il est automatisée
depuis 1987
d'une superficie totale de 3400 mètres
carrés le phare comprend à sa base un
vaste bâtiment rectangulaire
après avoir abrité pendant plus d'un
siècle bureau salle des machines et
logement du gardien
il accueille aujourd'hui une salle
d'exposition bel air est l'un des trente
quatre phares français classé monument
historique entre 2010 et 2012